I've opened up Backbone
source code here.
And let's refresh the page so that we
know that we're starting from scratch.
And now let's set up that object again.
We need a break point here so
that chrome will pause when we
try to call on from the console.
Great, now we can call on
to get the ball rolling.
There will be several function
calls in quick succession.
The important thing to notice
is that new information is being
passed along with each call.
First, InternalOn is called,
and adds this object.
InternalOn adds an events
property to the object,
which is the result of
the call to Events API.
EventsAPI is called and
passes the on API function.
The existing events,
if there are any, or an empty object.
The event name, the callback,
and some other contextual data.
Let's step into eventsAPI.
EventsAPI checks if
the event name is an object.
A string of multiple space
separated events, or a single name.
Our event is log.
So we end up down here.
The empty list of events, name,
and callback are passed to OnAPI.
When we started by calling
on down here in the console,
everything up to this point has
been verifying information and
adding new things that
are getting passed along.
We finally reach
the bottom of the stack.
Pay attention to what's
going on in this function.
Since this is our first time through,
events name doesn't exist yet so
an empty array is created.
Both events name and
handlers points to this same array.
We didn't pass any options,
so these are just undefined.
Handlers is the new array
that was just created and
an object containing the callback
function is added to it.
If we look at the current scope, you'll
see that there's an event's object
with a log property that's
an array of one object.
That object has the callback inside it.
The rest of the process is
returning this events object.
Lastly and most importantly,
remember that this event's object
is stored as a property
on the original object.
And that's it, so Backbones on method
adds an events object to the object.
Each key is the name of
an event to listen for.
And each value is a list
of callbacks to run